the Comedy Store would like you to know
that the views and opinions expressed on
this podcast are strictly those of the
speakers or authors and do not
necessarily reflect or represent the
views and opinions held by the Comedy
Store and its affiliates
[Music]
one of the world's Ava's counties or
podcast this is Dan in the morning and
with me as always this chuckle girls
okay yeah with the number one second
radio show in Bettendorf Iowa so if
you're in Bettendorf stop by Bishop
restaurant and get a piece of pie pie
we're comedies to our podcast yeah we
got low we'll take a slice of cream pie
thank you we did it in the faith one re
cream pie all lower yeah it's the ageism
own way to Boston cream pie the key lime
cream i honestly my first thought was
the house of pies i'm like it is
cheating
so today cheating okay I go to church on
Saturday I started early
a hostess have a class man is your time
it starts right at our communion and
choke down a chicken cheesesteak
standing off of my kid we would father
sugar all the free think through my
notes like save that while I'm gonna
have any gravy with dinner bring it
bring a French Dip up to the communion
altar I can't remember what a Walter
worst altar boy ever you were an altar
boy had to yeah I could probably and of
course me my brother were oh your
brother took a little too far yeah okay
money back for weddings you know jibba
do weddings you reiative yeah do you
think they invited me to ceremonies I
was like the we got a Saturday 5 o'clock
spot that we need to fill gull and
Ingram he's a [ __ ] loser
well you did it though right yeah I get
my ass out of the pool because you get
20 bucks cash sanim I never got paid any
money really yeah be forgiven and my
brother would give the tip back never
saw any memories you did guy never saw
not an effing idiot he's going to be our
Pope yeah I mean I legitimately had to
actually just steal money out of the
that's a very good okay is that where
you thought I don't believe in God so
don't worry there ladies no punishment
for me gain a new NASA navel I usually
listen to the Giants pregame listen foot
water Walkman you and apparently a
crying off and I ran it up my thing and
I would
we gotta sit there on the sidelines of
the Giants pregame when he said he was
leaving for like to cheat choke on a
chicken cheesesteak that's people used
to leave for the games you were leaving
for cheat day that's yeah I said like in
my heart I was like oh
although I do leave for Philly I just
did really like a couple weeks ago I
make sure I get there and time to get to
Reading Terminal Market to make sure
that any crush to mix and then overtakes
is one of the greatest things that is I
hit I hit that I hate the terminal I've
hit for noon before noon they're like
when they're still like just taking the
signs out yeah and this times up unless
you guys ready to go and I mean I know
I'm first online don't see much of a
line forming but I'll start one if you
need me to use coasters really I have no
idea you guys are talking about so I
don't want to go to any city where I've
seen Richie Taylor pose for photographs
wait a minute he came out when he was
introduced when they were introduced him
and his wife remember Oceana rocki rocki
rocki see weren't we all there were you
there I was wondering no I was area I
was all got fried Jean kind of person
the guy at the bar it was all outdoors
you know and Richie just soaked the Sun
in his melatonin just so good everyone
decided to all of Eli Ramos they all
just need a plan
brown brown has important with his
jungle skin yes talking in all the Sun I
I was me Eleanor Simone all of us just
whirling why did I have all the stupid
sunscreen at the bar we just want more
booze we got back to the comedy store we
look [ __ ] we were people didn't when
I was avoided I crave Larry the lobster
remember that n else I was I was parking
cars at the Comedy Store that night
which I was sorry I didn't know anyone
well enough to be invited but yeah I
just remember everyone showing up and no
one being no one should have been
driving car Ricci was my roommate right
yeah like if you first got here right
here would be written at as a TV show me
him and Mario and you never [ __ ] him
right no I was what Mario I had my
boyfriend you were you there when I got
hit by the car I wasn't there you live
it with an weren't living together at
that point he would that's why they have
that crosswalk outside of on Sunday hit
by a car Jesus who got hit you read a
lot
Barry what's a cold milk pink pink Tommy
oh yeah everybody got hit there slammed
shatter daily right really bad that's
different than when I got hit on the
motorcycle yeah different time but I
thought that time because that was
before I knew and that's yeah I thought
you live with him we weren't living
together I he when you were dating
dombarris oh definitely not
rere I wasn't dating I never dating or
even you just you which one took
pictures of you in the tree Dom bear
dombarris okay first baby's made it
going to intrigue normal for a state
that is right made for da that's
probably the most honorable I was part
of the ding dong you know for a little
bit I should have broke down mom take
her to the tree Dada
I remember I just hate I remember
because I parked over the big dog show I
remember you being in there Fidelma
waitress yeah I was the dumb waiter and
then it became Perry was like he'll
never get her and so it became a saying
like we had to make like we were on a
date sure so he took all these pictures
okay yeah it's important he still had
hair he was so cute
we were so fun yeah he we were doing me
what he called the public access show
Jimmy Kimmel was on it and dombarris it
was awful I don't a made me call Perry
as like a casting agent oh good and
because he didn't show up for something
we were like I was yelling at him I'm
like he'll never work in this town again
and Kimmel is just gonna pour more more
and I'm hearing him cry this means
everything to me my heart is just
ripping and a half and I'm like oh my
god I can't do this also he cried the
whole time in Kimmel's like yeah and
dombarris they looked in my head they
looked like two little devils dancing
around me and I was just doing anyway
the only guys I'm wearing shorts you
remember cheeser booked us on a sweet
gig at UCLA fraternity and did you doing
on Kate on came to you Don came with
Harry he made him stand in a bucket
latest and harvest pale input
cannot his head really so she's ER she's
er was cooking at a frat at UCLA
basically I've got to get down here like
or I convinced these guys put on a
comedy show 200 bucks or whatever it was
and it was like they brought in recruits
his recruit yeah I was like pledges so
they had a big lunch affair and he he
got me and rent is easy and then he had
Don Barrett's with Perry the headline
Windy City he was out I think but do you
remember her so be rehearsed or we got
there like you got the early accuse
telling how it's tipping up telling like
we're like where the stage allows you
yeah well we well basically just on the
bricks over and so then so don just make
space Perry stand we're gonna do a big
reveal Perry so yeah we're gonna put
this trash can over you just do not do
not move it's all the whole shell these
frat guys like an hour just like why is
that guys staying we all perform with
Perry still stay in there a Texas State
and he finally gets met Dodds like okay
that's the show everyone nothing else
the game never mentioned Perry it's so
like for two minutes everywhere I'll
just stay out of the laughing and Harry
finally takes a trash can off he's like
the rent is easy just drills him in the
head with a basketball yeah yeah so mad
it doesn't parent what why didn't you
say so I was like oh you weren't
supposed to take the bucket off your
head and then all the all the college
kids like who the [ __ ] is that guy is no
idea who he was it was beautiful what
did you think
I just love why do you see something she
said something Perry oh you're scaring
them of that [ __ ] whole time between
you and [ __ ] there is that it's so
awesome you're those big garbage you
could see lately 255 yelling trash for
my Chemical orientation Alba's mean
thousand with that thing yeah four
inches above his knees and then just his
feet down there recycles oh I would pay
a million dollars to see that it was
pretty amusing I'm sure she didn't film
it basically in no time I was too busy
smoking out of the chicken bone
the other cooks was this I think he is
only was Jamaican but he was from some
Caribbean countries black dude with long
dreadlocks okay and he would only smoke
pot out of an actual chicken bone that's
amazing she wanna hit up the chicken
bone [ __ ] pipe what's his name from
[ __ ] major-league Pedro Cerrano Babu
I forgot about that by the way we have
Steve Rannazzisi and Steve come on with
us that's right I got to do
last names because they're going to get
confused this one's ran is easy and
that's to usabout I know it's ominous
mouth we're all talking about really
miracl Simonis drops I don't like you
guys are here m'lady steve is a rosary
for us while we're on track - yep yeah
Steve's a good one
Simone is a good guy yeah the rest of us
aren't animals we are animals Steve
Rannazzisi do you go to church
mmm oh good you're in there you know not
every week I'm not uh yeah yeah hi
holiday your brother's a priest you know
I mean yeah like I would flow by right
well times that's what I'm hoping it's
like a free pass I'm just hoping I'm on
some sort of guess was yeah friends and
payable yeah your plus one
yeah I mean he's on my netflix account
yeah presence there yeah might as well
get me into heaven I gotta be honest to
you there's some strikes on the record
here yeah well it's not a strikes
integer named under my account a [ __ ]
fifteen years he's in going man
where does he go about where he priest
it up on the island so what we still he
them long yeah he's all about mother
matters you know the village loving no
she doesn't he doesn't know scaramouche
II damn the moment I can lose man it was
the best the Muji basics of s the best
11 days seconds of thunder yeah he was
he was crazy turned to work we were your
can change like we related to that guy
because he was on TV the sound was off
my god
I certainly don't I hope not but let me
turn the turn the volume up and then she
goes we're listening to them and then
they're playing that whole like she
bench at second
that's it that's was uh this is this a
sketch is this like I just feel like now
I'm this guy out there and see if anyone
buys it we'll just had enough see how
long people buy this this guy for is
amazing that's what Trump's doing he's
like what look look what I can do
21 days I was 2011 11 day 11 days and
learned had a great tweet he's like Tom
Brady spent more time in the White House
and the mood was spectacular and I mean
yeah he's from the myelin out that like
a worth of our people he got so many he
got a like this is like the like the guy
that's supposed to work in the White
House and he says this guy can suck his
own [ __ ] on like day one like that's
like his first prescott my ask my dad
like need to do does that guy you don't
even think I could say his own [ __ ] like
that would be like a reference that my
father would make not bad guy that he
suppose would be yeah I mean he got two
people that Trump wanted out to design
so feel like maybe the mood just was
supposed to come in which is good hey
man take two hours personality napalm
just to gather it all out yeah that's
the whole [ __ ] thing and that's it
moot you're going to be tremendous in a
week and a half I need you or Mario
Cantone he had such a good thing going
for 11 days be really funny on that dead
show oh yeah for 11 days and I wait
where did he do his on that president
shown on and come and Anthony and Tom I
can't say the last name yeah that yeah I
feel I'm like I feel like an idiot the
Comedy Central thing yeah yeah I saw one
funny skit on its rust it's just boring
not Mary I just saw the kinda can
telling thing he was good I just saw the
one where the guy is doing Trump and the
truck rolls down the street and he runs
allegedly improv but he runs out he's
like I'm gonna make to make the truck
honky-tonk and that agent goes to this
long rant man I wish I was driving that
truck I Drive it right down all the way
to the harbor he's into the harbor but
slowly the water would fill the truck
fill my lungs
Ilia at the AP dhaniya he's on vacation
right now leave the guy alone
no no that's not vacation he tweeted
about it guy whatever they're doing on
vacation to enjoy the water and pull
fish out for fish in there he's like you
tell me they love him I know they do it
he but he's like he really doesn't rate
us man that ever lived his GoPro guy is
top notch he always wears on come they
got him diving into the water and like
grabbing a fish with his bare hand like
pulling it out in like 30 seconds later
he's shirtless it's a two and a half
hour video
he's on a pontoon boat yep he's
shirtless hot enough to be shirtless
I feel weary I didn't even know her
water in [ __ ] Russia Larry I thought
it would like so she was like the Beach
City we have decided that the Winter
Olympics for some reason to worry about
this just [ __ ] broken lamp yeah they
had the Winter Olympics there because
they figured they could build a mount
the dead dogs large enough to do a ski
jump that's yeah by the way the Olympics
are here in 11 years you guys ready for
that I'm ready to marry you I'm still
here I'm ready to go out of town for a
month I think I will too if you leave
oppose the war halt oh I don't know why
you want to hear the Olympics in 11
years in America the holiday all day old
Wow yeah I don't go in that [ __ ] man
that's all we're going to be speaking of
Chinese that's not what my dad says when
I quit the debt once ago we want our
money I'll put my when I back on girl
when I quit me in the moping pot I had
like really weird dreams for a while
like I didn't have a dream for the 10
years that I yell good pot so I quit
smoking and then for like a week had
these [ __ ] can you see dreams that
areas are and the one reoccurring dream
I kept having was that I was just
working in a [ __ ] cubicle at some
Russian office which is me sitting there
no idea what I'm supposed to be doing
all these people talking Russia and the
cubicles around me and then boots that's
what I call him Chris close its eyes
then boots walks up and hands me a gun
and just set someone down on their knees
and I just had to execute them you're
like oh and then they leave and then I
just have to decide you know smoking pot
the next day I had to stop smoking to
get my life insurance test right I'm
still
after like three days three three four
days your brains like way to say we're
supposes our dreaming and and I go start
a convent and I was with Justin on the
road or my agent and we were talking
about
I don't wasn't Kellie Pickler but like
some like hot little blonde girl like
that and I had a dream that a night
after dinner she was there and she just
blew him in front of me but I watched an
HD HD like James Cameron like the car
working his meat being on time and I
woke up woke up and I was like I lit a
joint right guys like I gotta get this
back at least join me for the [ __ ]
life insurance that's smart
your life insurance that's all I gotta
that's all I heard you're nothing else
it's not even the meat I tried together
they won't give it to me because of the
diabetes that's what yeah Albert I'm
uninsurable so that because they call it
pre-existing I mean well I was different
life insurance yeah because it because I
have a way better chance of dying of
everything because on diabetes
hypothetically was having like an attack
driving or something like that yeah like
they say just you should get insurance
period no they just tried it would does
it know forget it like if you were a
smoker it's like three four times as
much I don't need times did I hit not
smoking like every time I was getting
insurance they're like do you smoke I'm
like no yeah but now they can obviou
that out yeah they like the comment I'm
like they took a hair of the ghetto
insurance that Mitzi gave me well no
this isn't for health insurance no
otherwise lighter yeah yeah oh yeah for
life insurance they really want to know
like everything they take a while ever
yeah they basically were like no you do
I knew I had a medical marijuana law
before I even call I didn't write it
down I go who's doctor so-and-so which
is the guy I go to [ __ ] on Van Nuys
Boulevard best doctor in the world you
may I go you mean my my body care
specialist
mind and body specialist yeah he's an
expert a lot uh can jump into the BB so
you know it's a real doctor - oh yeah
that's right medical diary I mean he's
got a license what did you say that was
for I said that was for my mind and body
and I said they go what do you mean I go
I have a medical marijuana card and you
know and the okay they just took that
into consideration you know that was it
yeah I remember going in with dice and
he was like here's $100 and they're like
you have to fill out this form he goes
you do it and the guy who were - the
guys never them - the guy sure I don't
know where you live yeah I'm not going
to have a wine III made the reservation
I was thinking about um Jimmy I don't
know why like his stupid joke that I was
obsessed with so Tommy's like new style
here sure not long
Jimmy painter nobody knows who this
person is yeah I would love to have him
on yeah there we go when he when dice
had him open for hand court he mean
Norton and Florentine standing on the
side of 90 to go well write this [ __ ]
out of each other laughing what - II we
were lat like you guys were laughing but
the audience was not now right not a
little bit every single time very bad
there never had been a cheat and Andrew
had shirts meditated I have a sweatshirt
I think with his names on it
oh your Norton Florentine you didn't I
dead joke you're gonna hate it's fine I
mean this is like well can we have her
people yeah that OJ Joe was like oh it's
is OJ Joe it was about how I didn't rush
really oh oh that guy's over 2,000 yards
in evaluated that was when they loved
her Blake yeah yeah hey Robert Blake's I
do okay you rubber button but you have a
rush for 2,000 yards at f-14 Gabe sees
as it granted that's when they let white
people they defense you kill yourself
what a little white woman and you just
here cricket cricket
oh my god and it's a nice crowd so you
think I'll be aggressive but they
weren't
translation is weird about seeing the
young Skeletor perform comedy is always
tougher people but Jimmy but he was just
memory and pain swinging and tagging
it's amazing that we all know his [ __ ]
yeah oh great
sixteen years later what he did to my
waitress we can't I won't their name
horse hair very short what a [ __ ] she
[ __ ] iPad it's 94 degrees the air
divisions broken she's a [ __ ] but when
she did that with the [ __ ] in the
bed on sway she was putting the legs
iron in your drinks she in my bed
enjoy our drink and then she just rose
her trade out it comes crying in the
kitchen and I could get between it like
a real adult like she's uh crying if you
see a pistol laying around it's mine I
gotta go so see the house I love your
condo how on earth you address a TV you
not only you sell me the condo that is
happy acquired me the mortgage and I'm
tests when I tell you that my mortgage
papers are signed the day of like the
you know like in the Great Crash like
what it was happening like like tick
tock like she called me she called me
she goes we got no home good news bad
there's ago what's the bed issues
Washington Mutual is no longer a bank I
go I don't even know what you're talking
about
that's they're gone Steve forget it it's
over I'm gonna get you another one I'll
be back in Wells Fargo she sends me you
know well try go I go yeah they're going
to do it now they bought Washington
Mutual Wells Fargo's your bank come in
tomorrow sign the paperwork I moved in a
[ __ ] month later fully every day
waiting and still eating day a family
you've to wait for the people to show up
like why are you in our house
some around ya place is great we were
subletting it to a Seabury onion
I don't please get out yes she God loved
her but she really was good I heard when
she did it didn't she so re something
did she do something for our yeah yeah
gonna Lum what on earth possessed you to
hire her
what you met her and you're like you
know it she's someone we can count on we
were working with someone else who was
like showing us like Muslim or stuff
that was out of our means and you're not
understanding that we were not willing
to go and evil or go yeah and then when
you when you need to go lower you look
inwards you know who can give me
something in the in a lower she was she
had like five places lined up we went to
look at five places and were like that
like we were never great at buying plays
like that one great let's do it how much
is it yeah no is it second yeah anything
where's Katie
I don't know she'll be here oh I mean
she's probably upstairs she might be up
to I don't know she's one of my probably
on the phone with Yelp trying to get her
name removed from so many bad reviews
that's comedy you ever hear that she's a
show that he had remember that Detailers
show there's like five or six times he
did in the belly room where you just you
could write whatever you want and go up
and and talk about it okay because I
wrote something would you be willing to
talk about just to read it for me
alright so I get there that night he
goes here and it was the combination of
the Yelp reviews from the Comedy Store
and my most about Katie yeah remember
yeah I mean like one of the first year
and like on our second or third date she
was like you ever read the reviews for
The Comedy Store like no she's like I
don't know who this person is but
there's someone named Katie that a lot
of people write if I'm talking like Auto
the review was like the woman yelled at
me spilled a drink on me then she left
she was gone for an hour gone for an
hour charge me double and then yelled at
me when I didn't leave a tip at all on
the double charge and I'm pretty sure
she I didn't really ruble charge I got
her no it was always like I think my
weight very intoxicated and the booze
you wanted to drink I'm gonna run
upstairs I'm driving oh you are are you
right how long you will see all right
off jack on the rocks
yeah your questions still work you want
me to go get it I'm an excellent
waitress I'll take a Jameson yeah you're
drinking out yeah let's do it
okay I have a ham so we lost around is
easy for a second because you can't do
without alcohol you know what if we're
going to happy for him we're going to do
this podcast they should really have
give us her own bartender when we work
hey that's a great idea
haven't I got Josh Martin working back
there four zeroes bill you might as well
come down here next strange to the crew
I'm surprised there's not more people at
that back bar I think it's the best
thing here well it's nice but he's cool
at first and now it's just it's like
people that know a guy that knows Richie
that's like who's hanging out back there
like it went from VIP of them being like
there's not enough you can't make money
off of comics technically so it's okay
if they bring a friend
cuz I only if they're cool though yeah
Frank's like not okay if you just want
to hang out with your friends and you're
not yeah right like in my case sometimes
I'm like carries up there she'll just
like invite people because there's no
comics hanging out so she's like [ __ ]
I'm going to go just generate some
business you know yeah or like or if
Doug Stanhope sin town they're like best
friends so who'll go hang out and he'll
bring a ton of people fun and then they
tip it I drink so she had to make money
that way but all that money he makes
selling used Buick than that to anywhere
it's all the time I love them that is so
funny
which oddly funny anyways so we're glad
to have you back on the podcast the
author Steve sim oh it's good to be we
had so much fun last night but I don't
remember all the stories we talked about
but I remember why I want it Jason Lucas
I know I just remember I had Opie like I
said no he probably he really wanted
yeah he really wanted to be on the
podcast but he's in Austin tonight what
a loser is he no editing yeah he's going
up for a local look but like if we could
get old-school guys all on at the same
time I got out of the stories yeah
because the club's so different now yeah
it doesn't have that it's you have to
really just feel like a treehouse that's
not an exaggeration it's just
felt like I'm just going to go hang out
with my friends well now it feels like
oh this is the center of comedy boom I
didn't get any spots this weekend
because the phone guy forgot to give my
avails to Adam I guess an item on my
night because someone canceled so a
jazel net canceled so they put me in his
spot because I was like how come I don't
have spots or like yeah you didn't call
it a nice lineup in the main rooms
incredible oh yeah like Segura Sebastian
Julia Ingram I know I'm not the
murderers row alright so I asked I love
you aren't you in there okay I said Wow
why do we have morons working here in
there like weren't you a [ __ ] that work
there I was like yeah and there was
eight people in the crowd and now it's
packed all the time and we can't afford
to have these morons there like you
never seem to care before I'm like well
they didn't forget to put me on the
lineup before now I had some skin in the
game I wonder let me ask you did that
ever happen to you no I'm gonna write
somebody down where I forgot they never
let me answer phones here they said I
was bad attitude so I had to worked
about the worker all the time yeah yeah
I not only work the phones but then for
like three months until Andrew made me
quit I was Duncan's assistant so they
positive bring me in on Mondays my whole
job is just writing down the avail
that's what I had to do for Scott day
and I hated it I loved being dumped into
the system was my favorite job here well
what was he we would just he would just
play a obscure crazy music and we'd have
laughs yes please
I don't know which one was good no hey I
bet you that one's for Jack yeah I agree
with that I'm going to always know it
yeah oh yeah tagore what horses well
where is he
very Endurance's hello oh they should
all come down at all I can work on I
want to do sets and stuff all right
that's all sorted I mean if they don't
want to come they could just [ __ ]
tell us that could be men about it
they're sworn enemies with both of them
that's probably why I mean I just don't
I just decided now that I should be I'm
just trying to create that I'm trying to
create those guys the way we were
talking about being a phone guy and
taking available did you ever have to do
that yeah
Mondays did you ever make and forget and
was the sheet but are you a Monday
collection during sex yeah they said
yeah they sent me a photo of the the
lineup that my name is on and there was
no exes next to any of the days I'm just
like this is a hard copy so I don't know
what to tell you like well what you
should tell me is [ __ ] that phone guy
he's fired and I will bump everyone on
the line up to give you a spot I'm not
doing that I give you spots all the time
I'm sorry I was like well this is the
end all right I don't know what to tell
you that I never [ __ ] up and I
remember like certain communities yeah
I'm not going to name names but like
would give specifically times yeah there
were people 9 in 10 a lot of people do
not write that down yeah a lot of people
do that now which makes me what oh yeah
yeah a lot of people and I'm like oh why
did I tell you lies I don't know that's
ok oh but people why why do we have a
disclaimer why do i why do people get
them write down what time they go on
because people are [ __ ] I don't I
just do [ __ ] they say whether they
earned it not just one email but there's
a few yeah the thing is though I feel
like you came to this place whatever
time you got that exam you're supposed
to go no matter what no matter when like
it was just it was how it went I mean I
was like just how many on dead last I
don't care I just yeah I just need um
you just wanted you don't want to follow
hope I'll follow it all day
I'll leave I'll bomb I will not get a
single life for 15 minutes if I can get
the money from that yes agent manual
checks are good now yeah that's what I'm
saying that's how I got to be 840 fifty
thousand graduation we didn't talk about
that partners list I thought you're
going to bring that up like Tommy I
thought about it but I didn't want to
brag or payment limits for comedians
came out number one Jerry Seinfeld at 69
million yeah but cracking the list this
year eight hundred fifty million
thousand million million fifty six
million Rick agree coming in at a fool
forty thousand
22000 - taxes without that yep taxes a
little bit for the manager in that and
and 440 nosy at 1099 that means that you
know I owed seven grand and here that
with the baby you take the baby into
that you're you only lost about 65 grand
last year and that's not bad there I
mean it felt good it was a it was an
increase of believe 86 percent you're
operating saltier a year from the year
before yeah that's amazing at least five
people died a past crispy chicken this
year yep like a rough year though
Christmas yeah yeah he's a billionaire
like you're talking saw a pitch for the
Seattle pilots in Zeitoun 60 throw it to
me on MySpace and he was like look that
was all an act and really have a lot of
money I thought it was Danish and
O'Neill [ __ ] with me those really
angers me I don't know but you know I
got that letter I found this letter he
wrote and my big bull rides was many
topping at number six
yes million just yeah Jim Gaffigan I'm
huge in ae-ja Mickey Mickey Mickey from
the open mike really made you regret
taking some of those staged on bears
photos where you were having anal
intercourse with him on a star I jump
that I joined hump that man my god wait
makes you just lay down up it just make
icon to see members watch oz Mickey put
your hands on the hood and let rena ZZ
have sex with you we're just doing this
for pictures yeah dombarris is making
you reg no no I was yeah I was like nice
to be funny this would be funny if I
just draw it could you show just such a
stoic figure and there's a lot of it
just look at the camera there's a lot of
photos so he's a man like you don't
really have a major star in Bollywood
yeah true that marry Dom what the Korean
actor bio
two-mile macchiato he was in hero's
right
is that the one words have no wait
Tamiya Otsuka yeah Maryana care yeah she
lives in Guam she swings from trivial
isn't yeah make you went to Thailand
with her and
and he decided over there he got booked
in a film in India and he has a [ __ ]
black card yes we talk business man this
agents a computer programmer what a
[ __ ] [ __ ] you man you don't [ __ ] up
the body would ya body would say you do
the field oh how are you doing how is
your I'm doing I tell you how to fire -
I can attack it hotter - wait a minute
how don't you know understand monitor
okay you come into my lives you make a
big mess I can make make a problem I
have a [ __ ] Julian Heath and I can't
have a heart attack if I do cocaine I do
cocaine and that's okay but how he do a
lot okay and I run I do looking colder
doctor tell me - do you remember when
you be here why you cook it Richie boy
Brenda Dee Dee's his mother ready
because he said - he said to everybody a
comedy store he said I hit a wife in
parking lot he was fat Jane come on he
would Jeff Jerry manager who told you
never to be on a jacket off my van oh
boy ready never give a dollar you get it
jacket cook never
Darla's [ __ ] doctor you remember what
Andrew said die sent all this food for
Thanksgiving or something but it was
like you know him being like all right
this under to the comedy stuff and some
but I don't know if I brought it or
somebody brought it and hook was digging
through everything and he was like hey
that does guy steak but a bone yeah yeah
no is turkey at the Saint Jimmy we go
hey Tara dies that can put a boom dog
meat on it
I got no brain
you know you got a [ __ ] bone here you
tell your kid coming I don't know
[ __ ] bone yes I got that but at home
I don't have to bring it born in
stooping a piece s epatha [ __ ] taco
you know a taco soup is so mad you know
taco it's I bring on taco here bring a
hot corner in [ __ ] Gina paper we're
putting one button a button nine button
you press of one button and a pop corn
that's already started doing the
impression would be Freddy sorry Freddy
Soto we took a little joy they like they
let us put the microwave in the back I
mean when you're on court burnin the
whole kitchen would smell you could
hardly lose your [ __ ] mind cookies
over you're doing with daddy turns
around and your fingering all the
pockets all the time yeah yeah you know
it's a month you can [ __ ] carrier not
a buffet all right when I said you don't
come in your seat you just push asleep
upstairs I don't mean you gotta [ __ ]
each other you Cherie the lime yeah you
had a cherry on your orange
didn't we don't get orange yes we gotta
tell a joke freaked out oh my gosh he
lost his mind
and we couldn't even help because we
were laughing so hard
you could cut through the black smoke in
the kitchen I don't know what painter
did but he burned the popcorn he got
mean I chopped corn one water hitting my
side buddies and hitting star he's like
and then he goes in like you know lose
it and it just burned I don't under like
Hawk the table with his primitive mind
has already figured out that like hurt
one button says popcorn like how he oh
it wasn't like the one who hated the
smell was going on he's dealt with
smells before look at this [ __ ]
gringo is so stupid he's grown up so
much more privileged so this is a
machine that makes it for you
it even has a button that says hit that
button to make this one thing for you
you're too stupid to [ __ ] figure it
out the [ __ ] one button why not one
popcorn you hit the one one you don't
have to hit a clockwise this button that
you start it just hit that one eight one
six one six
you don't even popcorn [ __ ] Freddy
to do the wrong road you don't why we
don't know why why any killed still gave
a little bit of context up front and
then I just and went into it yes [ __ ]
Mexico yeah yeah you look good fresh oh
that's good we're gonna have to be on
the Hampton Roads show her what i
catching from the parking lot when Huck
was dirty speech in the mat oh yeah yeah
in his last day here I thought you were
to say when he kicked me in and when I
put the sauce on right roll on his car I
like the guitar what do you mean I'm
[ __ ] what do you mean this is a tiny
little can it's not her don't tell you
again take it off the system pushes that
idea and I [ __ ] wheelhouse kicks me
right to the kidney
oh the ground yeah Oh buckled I would I
tell you go to put on the car now you
know no quick Ikey was a [ __ ]
superhero any try to give me a [ __ ]
one time I drove me home very weird in
the car Eleanor in Ireland it doesn't
hold up in my apartment my Reiser and I
was like I marry Liv he's like do you
want to talk and I said why smell my god
did you wanna here we go we don't know
each other very well
I don't making it up let me see your
helmet I'm not
that crazy [ __ ] alright I'll show you
the helmet helmet [ __ ] the [ __ ]
Liberty Bell you look like a [ __ ]
idiot fer it's a big dog crack it is Oh
that head almost as big as your head
wait did he really stop I'm telling you
[ __ ] up like if I pulled it out he
would not have minded like we just want
to talk you go wild is Saturday nights -
yeah like it is serious here though
everyone knows it does not does not tell
a lie talk to Washington to know when
people I asked she was so old a producer
made a world Rocky Hill goddaughter
myself today to look at ladies and
gentlemen oh my god I wish she was here
so we can rip alike you know what
driving here tonight what it's a great
thought as I and it turned so morbid I
was like I can't believe every room sold
out this is an exam I'm like it's what's
good what's going to make this go away
it's just going to take one comedian to
kill themselves that's it - could you
just give me that chin and I go yeah
coming guys and then it'll be a goal
soon again full circle I'll bring this
club but wait there's one more weekend
where my avails are not put in this club
mark my words I was just thinking that I
was like what it's like the you know
somebody that's not getting spot yeah
decides to [ __ ] I don't like that what
what is your biggest fear now with like
, mine is like that like I tell everyone
where I'm going to be so it's like if
you want to kill me I'm going to be at
Yuk Yuk's in Calgary
this weekend yeah okay what I'm saying
look I try my favorite rooms like a gun
in a colony because Club is like my
biggest fear still are you serious yeah
yeah kind of I think I hope that my
opposite my biggest fear is that I bring
a gun to a comedy club tonight
everyone in the audience you know that
the mass shooting records like today
your eyes it's like 50 like today's a
day for the big rain or some planning on
Monday rings become I think a little
planning and I could get 56 easy home
you can get away with this crowd up
there did I'm telling you there's no way
out half of them get jokes all I say is
look Feng Chao make sure that the doors
are locked on that side and then that
way there's only one way out new Huck by
the way he thought I love man yeah I
loved him past the keys he's angry
that's great but kind and Sandman key as
a mother functionary
he is great when he first showed up I
remember being what the [ __ ] is this guy
he walked out to me he's like a raking
him I want to talk to you about crowd
work like I literally had no idea who he
was from cyclone so my Asian I usually
wait a minute I want to do it how do you
do it those Josh Adam Meyers approach to
ask hey can I ask you a question about a
crowd work like yeah what's up man let's
say you a multiple what would you do
like what what no he did it that's what
I was literally what he said I got I
don't know it depend on the situation my
MA talking talking the cancer the wire
yeah and then uh and then some girl was
hit the very pennies like hey let me get
it on your vape pen she's like no and
he's like oh that's [ __ ] no one
other people sucking on my vape pen oh
man that's [ __ ] up it's like I gotta
get out of here well he's a great grad
work that's a good first yeah then take
that lesson I'm gonna walk over here
let's say you were on the altar are you
going to Baltimore is that what this is
about
it'll do yeah I need to know everything
you might be saying goobie devoted a
great club if you have been to Magoo be
adult I was there last Thanksgiving
Magoo peas yeah a real place the only
time to hear mr. Magoo bees the only
time I've ever had a problem with like
whatever whatever happened to me this
kinda front row was wasted the whole
night I got it in my head I'm like
wasted right they were kicking him out
he's out of the room he sticks his head
Bega's let's talk about 9/11
did he just be google me on the way out
the door I found out this today yeah I
saw what a great crack security they got
here let's talk about 9/11 human
Google's I saw some random girl tweeted
at me earlier said so Mike was your
wedding on 9/11 and it took me I was
like what the [ __ ] I'm talking about
and then I realized this kitchen this
driver three years just your parents
anniversary today's my parents 4080 my
dude I'm not talking about women holding
up your mom is still hot right that's
right wait you I thought that I did
honey three year you know we were a an
email earlier about the top particular
story so how Rick and mom being hot was
one of the topics but you were in the
trust tree I remember I remember party
Pete telling me sorry he gave me a kick
did I teach him he's still around snap
to the [ __ ] you know he came up to me
one night this was in the thick of the
Dean 15 they were all here every night
[ __ ] Hank what's them with the bald
one we saw many Dean any demon AJ now
fat rod does involve I saw that got away
here um yeah party Pete hot party be
walked up to me one night my mom wasn't
tough hey man I just talked to your mom
I got don't [ __ ] talk to my mom I
know she's beautiful I mean genuinely so
beautiful just god I can't even stop
what we're friends we're not friends
don't let there ever be an illusion that
we are friends because I make fun of you
regularly frightening I'm friends admit
see this is the problem the bank
friend's party P&C 1515 there's so many
we wonder why there wasn't an audience
yes way to a [ __ ] gaggle of misfits
we can get in the white dragon oh my bra
you just do the math bro yeah it was a
swap shot out front they have people
with someone with the hair on it fro the
the author of kick flip Cameron the
worst screenplay I've ever read in all
my life well 220 pages of vampire
skateboarding movie that
and a to be continued genius to be
contain who'd you write it in a
composition notebook like Tommy wrote
his pilot first alia for a very special
episode of Whitney for Dooley our stove
always reading the Michael Kosta as I
turned the corner in the main room that
bad wait I saw it a common on Eliza me
and I just really bad way like sorry
dude this is on you let top opposition
oka Brittany says first of all I used a
mechanical pencil
alright not gonna ball lick that thing
three times Whitney respects me that's
not true at all shouting Tommy I
suggested the show so he know that he
grow his hair out like Julia did he
listen know he taught me the show's
going on
Wow there's no one in there right now
there's four people and I pocketed their
money
oh alright Tommy that's partly I gotta
go upstairs
play my guitar think about things I'm
not going to tell staff that ham a quart
low that's a Camaro permit because it's
audience applauds a fat chain no one
worth it wait he didn't originally I
guess and a quarter quarter James and
Tommy Morris I'll do it all right not
only Meredith I'm asking you guys
[Laughter]
[Music]
Gallagher's Oh when in the cart need fat
James and Tommy Morrison Maura
Hey
Papapa Papapa
she said you makes a car stank you're
fired
I'm wearing a purple teal or in a purple
suit like this how he say every cheese
wedding he looks like oh wait he sang a
song oh yeah all was it went at James
wore that blue suit he looked like
violet from the wheel won't ask you she
might ADA this is it
this mother's place respect me what
what's the song he said shaggy
hello mr. lava lava mr. lava lava
they call me mr. boombastic oh thank you
coming over the Belushi night no oh come
on water speeches the lowest of the low
is when I was out of town for some
reason I was kicked out of my apartment
early 2000s allegedly how history will
be broken and I was a transient are you
living on Ari
all right but there was no one more fun
one fellow er I slept in a food truck
futon Inari's re the living room it was
bad after they dip is bald ah yes all
right a lot he would write out chores
for me in the kitchen in the bathroom on
the moor in the mirror like because you
did this you have to have to live here
here in Jordan and then even I came
there I came here from Simone's because
he lived with fat James and fat James is
gone so I put my air mattress on top of
fat James's bed but the smells would
Allah would have locked up around me and
concluding me I just left in the middle
of the night one night I was like I'd
rather sleep in the street sorry no way
that's cry yeah he he was so sad when I
finally came over to watch
sushi movies with them and I stayed for
one movie and I was literally like just
stay to the ends guys very sad just do
it
I stayed to the end of Animal House and
then he's like look what it blows
brothers like I really gotta go what do
you mean it we only watched one Belushi
movie alone sad moment I was like I
can't love that because I don't like you
oh he was the first person I met at the
Comedy Store
no they kicked me out of the parking lot
yeah Blair yeah he was yeah I was in the
taxi filling out like we know whatever W
forms you have to fill out and he comes
over the kusa [ __ ] car is in the part
you sent your car in the pot there's
like a business remember that parked
your car where you worked you know like
a business look wait wait you must be
great at Natick is that I hear yeah he's
like I'm like I didn't know he did I
don't know the [ __ ] Hill in a Bobby
Lee bring you up on a Sunday night
before that he had introduced me yeah I
remain me not at night and then I'm like
no James's a new employee whoa right
over I remember Lucas in the manager's
office right I'm engaged in Lucas right
because I calling the manager I got his
feet up right like this I mean obvious
introduced me is like he's like oh yeah
he knows Jon REEP you and Lucas you know
John rate I'm like yeah I never January
but come on mutual friends I have to
live with them I'm like really like yep
I know I'm real well I'll find out if
you know I'm like Jesus Christ
especially right away
mafioso we'll get to the bottom of this
I'm so comfortable because I'm talking
them the door guys like schedules at
that point well ahead mafia yeah did he
make you step outside while he called he
um John really be quiet you know I'm
didn't take his call I think Lucas was
smart enough to know like I just put a
message on a pitch and we all [ __ ]
straight to the mill John raccoon comes
over dies around it's a sign it's
somebody King double in and out to the
Crescent Moon this week on Appalachian
Mafia Jason Lucas hires red is easy he's
got eight kids now eight Wow his kids
are tremendous debt exaggerating every
I think I have like eight yeah right how
does you have to use one I have one I
feel like endless they're like gremlins
that's how I feel like there's only one
but I can more exhaust it every day
are you allowed to tell the story of
what happened when you got locked out
yeah it doesn't matter
my wife Hardy knows what a failure I am
as a father it would you do needs - my
wife has flowers out on the patio and so
I noticed they were dying and I thought
hey you know I should probably do the
right thing you'll see if these things
need to be watered or whatever
so maybe was playing I slid open the
sliding door I move the little bar out
from whatever it is I walk out and then
I look at it for like five seconds I
just hear this bang we have these uh
honey close the door in you she there's
a some sort of a blind plantation blinds
I think they call them yeah like these
long or down yeah that's racist though I
have those they're sitting they are new
and she crawls up and just smashes the
plan the updation blinds against this
door and it just pushes the bar right
back into the to the sliding door
locking me out no it's just like oh my
god of all the moves like just are you
on the Harris floor yeah okay yeah so
I'm just gonna student now yeah it's a
terrace a condo okay yeah so you got to
pull doneall o'neill when he got a
luxury box he got it you got it he snuck
into a luxury box sometime at Staples
Center and they ran in a beer he snuck
in
then he he went on the outside of the
luxury box and snuck to the other luxury
box on the outside like spider Rider man
long decided and snuck into their luxury
box yeah yeah so nobody stopped him no
why would you try to stop O'Neil easy of
maniacs [ __ ] climbing the other one
you go sir sir what's in your mind right
now yes sir
I see someone climbing on the outside of
a luxury box I go who do you call here
so I I like real old [ __ ] know what am i
fool I called the locksmith I said look
I need you to get here ASAP
and I just I would have them just opened
the front door yeah cringe at work so
I'm just standing like sake call the
locksmith guys like yeah I'll be there
in 10 15 minutes like [ __ ] alright
what's the baby doing at this at this
point baby making self breakfast she
crawls over to the biggest cheeks are a
few obvious little arms and legs only
diaper engaged yeah she I mean Stay Puft
is what I call or is it make you to use
walks over to the glass part of the
sliding door just starts banging on and
smashing her face on it to say look
terrible did you you're charging me she
went behind the house your daughter yeah
she'll never ask you like one day I'm
going to start smoking pot again she
open up girl that joint just live it you
like you think I'm you think I'm not
smart dad I gotta go upstairs guys I got
a spot yeah I love you guys come back
we're not ready yep you're yeah a couple
more minutes yeah so she locked me out
and then right right at that moment
Corinne lobby bye thank you for the
third Corinne texted me and was like hey
can you go on my computer and do this I
was like now I'm already [ __ ] I can't
because the baby just locked me out what
is like you're a horrible parent I'm
just like oh yeah I am right now
what is it locksmiths I'm just imagining
you like Michael Keaton and mr. mom on
that day where everything goes exactly
one funny show me yeah yeah like the
baby's eating bean yes yeah the
locksmith showed up and by 15 minutes
flew by and baby's just standing at the
door just gawking at me like what a
loser I am a locksmith like all like
what's the deal uh no no hear traffic
will probably be there in 15 minutes
opposed to be 15 minutes 15 minutes ago
so the dude finally shows up is like 35
minutes and the whole Julie just stood
at the door the whole time like thank
God let me out I think I won't let her
come out but aa
trapped then the guy shows up on my yeah
man I just need to get in
you know my baby locked out oh it's a
foreign guy of course Oh baby is inside
yeah man baby's inside okay
then he just walks up to the front door
stick some piece of metal and the
[ __ ] doorknob I'd hate it with a
[ __ ] screwdriver and the whole door
just opens up I'm like well that's
uncomfortable
you know that was that easy but Wow now
are you just hundred and twenty dollars
thank you it's emergency yeah but you
didn't get a bucket here's $120 and then
later that day got some sort of a rebate
for something in the mail and like
others a check for $100 immediately
Crim's like oh cool that almost pays for
the locksmith I had to get because you
were such terrible dad like okay sounds
good even-steven that Seinfeld episode
yeah
that's it's but that kind of [ __ ] has to
happen like I think about my mom with
all of us I don't think she'd ever get
locked down because I don't even know if
we had long slimmer kids yeah different
time early 80s you wanted to I'll break
it yeah I think we did especially cause
coming in my mother's house it's Grand
Central Station for chrissake yeah
there's so many people in there you're
going to run into at least one carriage
it was a baseball bat it's a terrible
house to break into yeah there's too
many bats they're doing you know dick
ball bats wiffle ball bats you name it
we had it tennis rackets those were good
to hit with it's a solid flat wire sir
fun it's a weird he's a weird mark yeah
question you broke into my house my
brother Jimbo 100% gone Kevin
McCallister on you it's really [ __ ]
shadow how is Jimbo
I'm gonna head kids are good man they're
they're five and three and
oldest kid is going to be a first grader
youngest gets a preschool I got a nephew
going into first grade and I can't stand
it yeah yeah it's great but my daughter
turns one at midnight ah I can't even
believe a years gone by and it feels
like 10 years and in one day at the same
time so yeah that's what they said like
the first two years was like that's how
I feel about life Oh pick
Huck's been gone for what five years now
like what are you doing the impression
I'm going almost lost myself hawk-like
you know it just all goes by so fast
like the Dean 15 has to be what eight
years ago now probably's ago yeah
probably at least five or six years here
they're still around when Corinne and I
started dating subject so they're the
Dean fifteen yes in the other nine years
Wow Wow
yeah because when I started doing
stand-up I'm 10 years and I kind of
remember the big hair guy yeah he was
such a sweet kid yeah anyone Ellie yeah
it's so nice yeah total piece of [ __ ] go
only there's only great guy great guy
piece of [ __ ] yeah he was part of the oh
it's super nice if you would have just
shown up and not been associated with
the crew he was associated with would
love the guy but based on being a member
of the beam 15 like number 12 on the
beam of texture Larry Lola Greg yeah you
know but number one Jill
Alan because you shed the world we
already got trouble for that whole name
yeah yeah what are you gonna do so a
fantastic Comedy Store podcast fan sent
me a piece of mail and I got the Comedy
Store and they're like there's a package
for you in the office we're not opening
it I was like thank you yeah I got I
don't know what take dicta and uh yeah
so I'm expecting like better be so wet
weapons-grade what was that powder they
someone a son in 9/11 and rash
weapons-grade anthrax it was a DVD copy
of Christa Lea's first movie bad girls
from Valley High oh that's great and in
a note that just said so like [ __ ] geol
Island love the comedy short podcast
like we did with the correct I was like
this guy's awesome so I was very excited
to get that you watch Christmas movie I
mean I watch the years ago when Chris
Berg showed up
just Corinna's like yeah that Chris
guy's in a movie called bad girls from
Valley High and like can you download
that because I need to see that
immediately
and it was awesome it's [ __ ] terrible
if you get the chance and I pretty
probably won't so I think I have the
only DVD copy on earth but Aaron Paul
Chris D'Elia
the lady played Reed on Dexter and I
mean it's kind of like a lot of talent
for a movie called what was it called
bad girls from Valley High it was made
in the 90s
Julia was like 18 or 19 he said it was
originally made they thought it would
like be competition for dude where's my
car is that era gotcha and then it just
got shelved for 10 12 years and they
released it after that yeah they just
released it in like 2008 or something on
DVD and it had a different name
originally that's that was the name
they're like what have we changed the
name to bad girls from Valley High we
released this thing and someone's like a
green light immediately
Julia plays the the jock he's like the
alpha male jock he's gonna was like
short hair right he was Jack yes I
thought like muscle yeah very mostly and
his hair is like short spiky and if he
muscle email or it's he Justin he's kind
of mushy like I don't look at things
like that weird yeah yeah I think you
see I think he's gotten more mostly in
the last couple years but he was like
Jack then I was like a belt in jujitsu
I've been on HDA now I don't run that
this is per seen Aaron Paul of of course
Breaking Bad Fame plays the dork and he
pulls up in his like Pinto or whatever
his shitty hatchback car is parts of the
school parking lot and then D'Elia rolls
in in his monster truck could just
smashes into the back of a car just gets
out it's like dude move your car you're
like oh this is spectacular somewhat
like yeah dude move your car dude move
your car bigger dudes and you in prison
that kind of vibe that's amazing right
boot I don't know I have $20 they rely
never how long were you did they make
you I should say be the manager here I
feel like that was a surely a year 9
months 10 months
and I wanted to get out because I was
always afraid of getting fired for no
reason and door guys were making more
money possible we had $25 a night yeah
no they would sell buco and other
illegally make oh oh yeah then the
second I gave up being the manager they
paid that they started to pay the
manager hourly and gave them benefits
and I was like really god I was making
building really don't have any $5 a
shift and I get here a1 and state of
3:00 in the morning or yeah that's what
I was like 12:30 but it's not real Steve
I got I got five minutes gonna take you
know who's real Zell Dorf the largest
cricket of the batch he's one who
created your precious little god whoa
whoa I like that I know I didn't know
they were making money I forgot they
were selling booth nails they make ready
the comedian's make the least amount of
money in the building I will get twenty
bucks a set everybody makes more money
yeah
I'll be on in the o.r and for the first
couple seconds on stage I'm like they
need new drinks I could be making money
yeah the way they have to be killing it
now yeah
killing it I'm knocking at people and
I'm not like thinking of what I can say
about I'm like oh your drinks empty yeah
it's frightening why am I looking at
that like even a main room could rain
mayroom spots are great but it's still
we're still making the least amount of
money in the main arm true the door guys
are making more yeah
and they and the waitresses and they
split I mean the waitresses Oh like you
need to do comedy for 20 years right
20 years of working hard writing
sacrificing everything you have yeah and
if girl could show up that afternoon
fill out an application to make more
money than your that night we have some
real [ __ ] it's the truth we get raising
really think is right know what happens
how you're going to say we have some
real thinking to do about our career no
I wrote about me for the money you do
comedy because it's a calling
I've already been not structured I've
got a short period of time and then I
[ __ ] get a new gig so how much time
you think you got
I'm guessing I've got according to the
timetable I was given by my my wife I
have until Julia or our youngest child
is in kindergarten and then at that
point I'm you know it doesn't matter if
I'm slicing deli meat at Ralph's I have
to choose a different career why
so it looks like Ralph's in Agoura Hills
is going to be there you have a new
headliner and no one slices deli meat
not an application Adam beyond that I
might be with you guys I would rob
society I did everyone say when they
change over their flyer I'm like let's
see what's on sale this week hey that's
a bore of my life yeah there's a flyer I
grew up at the app on my phone like down
tears I love to eat there like I don't
learn how to cook this is man this is
the new school lunch menu for you it is
that's a great and somebody just gave me
ten minutes uh yeah what do you mean
like so you you have an app on you have
an app on your phone I don't have apps
ready because where I'm at darling I've
ever they stop mailing out their flyer
so you have to figure out what's on sale
oh you mean like their little coupon
though yeah the liar now gets sent to me
I got it my mom used to cut all the
coupons for ya and now they're all
digital right and then and then she put
them in a pile and then we go to the
store and they rewrite in that pile
where she left them and never never with
my mom loves to just spend money extra
money more money the reason why I decide
on the deli slicer profession yeah is
there a like a sin extra cent I shaved I
almost say ma'am has to be shaved for me
I know yeah okay so a joke then I I grew
up kid down the street from a kid named
Whitney Coulter great name nice enough
kid I think I was a little a little
crazy I think sometimes I just remember
he hit me in the head with a wrench when
I was in the fourth grade I won't even
show you this three stooges ward never
one wooden part what because he Lance
Murdock who ever was
a daredevil that oh hello Whitney
Whitney Coulter his dad worked at is
yeah is a guy like Whitney Brown yeah
Whitney's dad worked at a at the
henhouse market in the deli section okay
and he was also the neighborhood
alcoholic which was very exciting and
recall one night hearing a lot of
honking kind of like wow probably
between 12:00 and 2:00 in the morning
and not my bedroom paced out front so I
just kept hearing it he lived only a
couple houses down and after a while you
heard yelling and then everyone kind of
was awake and I was going to see what's
going on in the neighborhood quiet
suburbs wise their constant honking and
someone yelling and all the neighbors
were out and once you're watching he's
just screaming obviously his wife had
told him he's not allowed to come home
that evening because he was so drunk
whatever was he's young I paid for this
house woman I saw woman I sliced meat at
the hen house market to pay for this
house you want to tell me I'm not
allowed to come in well I'm coming
handed and they got this car and just
drove through the garage door I was just
like Bravos everybody man checkmate so
I'm hoping that that's it Darrell I want
to again your channel with him Rio how
many commercials have you booked this
year they don't pay [ __ ] anymore it
isn't that weird like I did a Popeyes
spot I ran for a month
at this point I've seen like 1,200 bucks
or something get outa that's not my
stuff we went in for yeah he got it and
Alex Thomas got it yeah yeah yeah Alex
Thomas got the spot you tried out for
they said to go with the black family
yeah at least I made it to the white guy
yeah that made me feel good Thank You
Neil for bringing man yeah Neil I mean I
got a call back I think that was my
first one you all said if they were
going to go honky I would have been
doing you yeah that's what I told me on
set honky Simone we just keep Simone
lined up and then they went with black
family I was like you know I think would
have been a great black father Cecil
hahaha I love Alex Thompson I'm happy it
is so exciting just to see like oh one
of us got it yeah you know it was great
I was at like the Sherman Oaks Galleria
like maybe a month ago there's just cute
little baby kid and she just smiles I
mean I'm like you know I like when dogs
model kids think I'm nice and they just
come up to me and it was out Thomas's
daughter I'm like we're like a Prius so
so cute right
and she's like looking at me and just
comes over and like starts talking to me
and Alex like oh my god it was all bad
yes you're talking to a weirdo but then
I told you I got that baby talk to the
white man okay it's okay it's okay he's
called oh great yeah he's a sweetheart
I forgot my house wanted soon as she
knew she was ill oh yes I did yeah
because she feel she was in the car like
in it's like all strapped in a little
bundled in with our little cute girl I
wanted to bite her face in I like to
play with kids I just like to drop them
back off like I'm excited I'm going home
next week we're not doing the Pete Rose
rose because if I can what happened with
oh there was a few more kids 15 year-old
okay okay that's hard that's what
happened yeah that's what everybody for
they graduate on bobblehead but this is
I don't know but this is that thing
he isn't such a jackass first of all
when I was writing these jokes and like
researching him I'm watching I'm like I
[ __ ] hate this guy like whatever I
was learning I was like I cannot stand
the [ __ ] guy and then he was on a
radio show this the 16 year old thing
that was already out I was like in the
seventh yeah but it would happen when he
was having the lawsuit with doubt when
he was trying to that they discovered it
when the gambling [ __ ] happened Johnny
yeah all that when he was under
investigation I came out yeah so in but
nothing came of it they had no because
of it being 16 was the legal limit in
Ohio he's in Ohio right okay but now he
was on a radio show not too long ago and
he's arguing with this guy and the guys
like well you were you're a statutory
rapist do reduce blah blah blah and he
goes no I got clear too that he goes she
was 16 and he's like no one with a guy
he was arguing with was like an
investigator he decided to look into it
a little more and apparently he took her
to
Florida yeah wasn't six low men for
spring training and that became a
federal maintained in Florida so so
that's what opened it all back up now I
don't know if he can get convicted or in
trouble for this right now
yeah I think the statute of limitations
is passed which is crazy that in this
country that there's a statute of
limitations for sexual crime yeah I
think the real crime here is the way
Pete Rose used to wear his hat on the
top of his head while calling it down
here really agree with you how do you
have Jim Carrey's haircut from dumb and
dumber
and then just rest a hat on your head
hahahaha what a goddamn fool hit King my
ass one of the jokes I had was uh and
actually somebody gave this to me and it
made me laugh with it I had a few about
that statutory rape thing but this one
Jason law had gave a serious I love I
love these so we're just walking around
in Vegas and he was like worst bet Pete
Rose ever lost to his barber that's fine
it does alaria but yeah I mean I had so
many jokes like but at the same time
we're still going back though right
that's always gonna say yeah so I'm
going back I'm doing a bunch of other
stuff but we're going to wall wood nice
what all the kids because my nephew
who's told those wild well Wow would
days I'll have all the kids will be
playing on the beach so excited I want
to buy a house it's a Jersey Shore neat
I just feel a little bit and there's a
condo and nice and they're not that
compared to out here that I I just want
to buy a room in PJ's house I think you
should but that was different our
teachers or the two people we got in
trouble for we keep bringing goddammit I
can't use your new friend today I'm
digging myself into a deeper grave but
how funny was run ADIZ he he had me cry
he's CrossFit right always on stage
right Saturday night Steve on Saturday
night Saturday night what's upstairs
yeah I had to go now let's go upstairs
not last um thanks for listening Steve
you got anything you want to promote you
have social media once just come out
we're next week gonna Comedy Works in
Denver this week so I don't know you put
in a good word for me yeah a lot of my
gosh Wendy's great and I think wife is
about love you dude everybody I don't
know why you're not out every weekend no
one wants
book they predict whether the social
media following that nor credits will
change it we're going okay holiday
weekends I don't care I just need to get
out city weekend like I work in the
comedy works but not in Denver in
bristol PA oh that's great okay it's 11
and 12 there's a deli slicer I'll do it
no we don't need one because we can go
right into South Philly or Center City
and go to the Knicks and the John the
Knicks used to be on 10th in Oregon that
was my sister used to make normal Oregon
wouldn't make me walk all the way there
to get a roast beef I mean I brought my
ovaries jobs on Snyder and he had never
been that so good oh my god no jelly he
never been the terminus shut up I'm not
you know why she's northeast yes the
Northeast like the Delco of the mill I
got to be honest I did go to John Stowe
I was um older but definitely so sorry
sorry I have no idea what this is all
for my brother Tommy and Johnny oh now
listen to my brother wah wah [ __ ]
straight Tommy's been listening for a
while and email told Johnny to listen
now Johnny calls and critiques every
week let that go for me so everything's
working out John from what I understand
johnny has been hooking up with a Mario
hello whoa what does that mean I'm not
sure I'm not sure he hates more real
yeah hates all nobody it plus he knows
me very Oh Mario is well thank you very
much Mario real quick Mary I've gotta go
up some blazing yes you are so hot right
now I'm losing weight and I'm glad
they're videotaping thanks for listening
everyone come to the comedy store check
out a show before you come though call
ahead make sure that my avails were
given to you later please call in and
request it check out my podcast good
time yeah thanks to rent is easy Simone
thanks to hawk for flying in this body
and yeah keep listening thanks yes
please Philadelphia if you're there
check me out warm daddy's do a comedy
works August 11th and 12 and then parks
casino on this thing is in Philadelphia
trust the process I'll be slicing mean
as the
encounter out to the goryeo got Caden
bro thanks guys
[Applause]
you
[Music]
[Applause]